[Music]
shawn
is with us sean is in denver hey sean
welcome to the dave ramsey show
big dave anthony how you guys doing
great man how can we help
all right so the skinny is
i've got about 46 000
in debt i just started a new job
in 45 a year um my question is
you're making how much 45 000 okay
and i've got a car that i'm slightly
upside down on
and um i got a question about that okay
so what do you owe on the car
probably like it's around 11 000 like 10
6 and i think if i were to sell it
privately i could probably get around 10
for it so it's not too bad
but i'm wondering if you know if i was
trying to get because
i would need to replace the car and i'm
figuring i need
a couple thousand for that do i try and
sell the car
get a small loan to pay the difference
or a little more to get another car you
could why don't you just pay it off
yeah it's eleven thousand dollars just
pay it off what kind of car you shine
uh it's volkswagen golf oh yeah yeah
what's the other day yeah because i
don't think we need to lay on
i see what you're trying to do you're
trying to get aggressive and go after
the debt and if you're that was 28 000
on the car i'd be selling it in 30
seconds
right but eleven thousand you're not
making 11 000 and you end up with five
or six
thousand in uh covering the amount
you're upside down plus you're covering
another car
you haven't moved the needle much i
think you can pay it off almost as easy
what's the other 40 something what's the
other 30 some thousand dollars in debt
though
uh it's 25 in student loans okay
about 50 300 in credit card debt
4 000 in medical and then like 1500
and miscellaneous and you're how old
27 yeah and you're working 40 hours for
45 000 now
yes sir okay cool yeah yeah i think the
biggest thing is not your cards your
student loans i think here sean
um we got to step back and just really
work the debt snowball man yep
you know i think that at the end of the
day just work the death snowball
i wouldn't worry about trying to get a
loan to go for this car or not just just
pay things off get to the student loans
and get
re get really aggressive with that so
here's what's happened
something occurred that woke you up you
got the cold water splash in the face
and you went oh my god
and then you got a new job and you got
some opportunity to clean up the oh my
god yes
the oh crap moment right there and uh
and so it's all kind of new to you
but anthony and i've been doing this so
long it's really easy for us to jump in
and go we can start seeing these numbers
and going
and you just list these debts smallest
to largest you pay minimum payments on
everything
but the little one you attack the little
one with a vengeance yes
which um i'm sorry sean but you have no
life for a while
yeah your only life is going to be
working your job and your extra job
because 40 hours a week isn't enough
we need you to go ahead and pick up
another 30 hours doing something else
so you can clean this mess up really
really fast the more money you make and
the less you spend the faster you get
out of debt that's the formula
yes and you pay off those little credit
cards you chop them up you're going yeah
i'm getting some progress here then you
reach over and pay that car off yep
and then there's down to oh ugly sally
may which is way more than half
of your debt and then you just start
punching her in the face repeatedly
until she finally gives up the ghost
and you knock her out but you know if
you make an extra 10
15 000 a year as your side gig divide
that into 40.
what if you made 20 as your side gig
divide that into 40. that's two years on
the side gig and you're out of debt
not to mention we're cutting your life
away and you're going to live on nothing
on your 42 thousand
now you're out of debt in 18 months with
the whole stinking puppy
but the next 18 months is going to be
known as hell on earth because all
you're going to do is work
you are not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
that's oh dave you hit it don't eat out
heck i even say probably don't even date
the next two years
yeah i wouldn't go that far you can get
a cheap date
oh no no telling you you're not gonna
die but don't tell a woman
you know she's a cheap date dave i
didn't say her but it said the the
spending
i get it but this generation but the
generation will receive that she's a
cheap date
he's 26. i know but you're a cheap date
i'm not
you're cheap i know you're cheap and you
go on dates i
i am cheap you know you know i
am cheap you know well i'm not cheap i'm
frugal hey anybody put that on me
you got these young ladies out here like
wow is anthony a cheap date for
real yeah it's worth i'm just not he's
worth
every penny he's not going to spend 500
on that date no
no i'm not doing that no that's not a
cheap day that's just a wise date
yes 500 yeah oh my god let's not bring
that back up
oh okay we don't need to go back there
you get hate mail every time i do this
so and then i get hate mail but i don't
read mine that's the difference so
all right so sean yeah the more you're
willing to sacrifice the more intense
you're willing to be
the faster all this is going to go away
and i think you keep the car
yeah and you use it to deliver pizzas
yeah yeah and sean here here's the thing
what's down the line
um i want you to get a free ramsay plus
for a year for this process because i
think the key ingredient for you
is to really get on a good budget that's
going to really help you
stay the path and stay the course
because this is the thing
ramsay plus is the thing that got me out
of debt
but it caught it required discipline and
required a plan
and i think you need a plan and work